new satellite pictures depicts the
Caribbean before and after Hurricane
urban hit before images show the Turks
and Caicos Islands are lush green resort
destination but the powerful storm
stripped its vegetation and destroyed
houses Tony de copal is in San Juan
Puerto Rico after he left Saint Maarten
where thousands of Americans were
stranded Tony good morning good morning
the families who landed here in San Juan
had to survive for nearly a week after
Irma ravaged the island of Saint Maarten
they got by in shelters on rations
hiding from looters and they were never
quite sure when they were gonna get home
until they saw the National Guard c-130
s start to land take a look
we've just touched down in st. Maarten
with the Puerto Rico National Guard
where they expect 300 to 400 Americans
to be waiting for rescue right here at
this gate the hope is to get these 300
people on board and on their way home by
nightfall because it's been a journey
just to get to this moment
at a makeshift security gate guarded by
Dutch and US Special Operations Li he'll
Gartner is rushing to vent passengers
for the flight home what we're doing is
trying to process the American citizens
that are that are here on st. Maarten
we've been getting the medical like
emergencies out but there's still people
who have been staying in relative's
houses there are other people's homes
Hurricane Irma slammed into st. Maarten
as one of the strongest storms ever
recorded what are the last few days been
like hobble but for many there the
aftermath was even more menacing we've
heard about there been reports of
looting and rioting yes yes
back at the security gate and they have
ones he'll Gartner finds a spot on a
charter flight for Susan coke can one of
the many who lost nearly everything in
the storm did the storm that looted and
robbed blown my place blew up 40 years
of my life
the tarmac fills with even more people
all of them cleared for the flight back
to San Juan and back to America after so
many days on edge sleep comes first for
a lot of the passengers but when the
door is open it sure feels good to be
home
the National Guard and State Department
personnel on the ground they're believed
375 Americans got out yesterday and that
brings it to just about everybody which
means today finally the mission there
can shift from one of rescue to recovery
charlie
thanks Tony to cope will in Puerto Rico
I tell you people when you get off you
don't know how they feel and you can see
just the relief on their faces yeah it's
tough and the appreciation to nor again
about the kindness of strangers that
sort of get you through this I mean the
pressure is everything it's emotional
it's physical it's fear all right and
you don't know what you're going home to
do after all of this